i
[Música]
bienvenidos a esta edición especial de
los observadores de france 24 estamos
siguiendo muy de cerca la guerra en
ucrania y los cientos sino miles de
vídeos de aficionados que son publicados
diariamente
utilizamos técnicas o xing es decir
información de fuente abierta para
corroborar estos vídeos participamos
también en un proyecto global para
verificar estos vídeos y ponernos en la
web hablamos con el coordinador de este
proyecto canaima spain yemen street and
it de renta o venta station me llamo
benjamín street soy director de
investigaciones del centro for
information presi lens una organización
británica sin ánimo de lucro que se
dedica a investigar y contrarrestar la
desinformación y las operaciones de
influencia
complex especialmente en relación con
los abusos de los derechos humanos y los
lugares en conflicto como lo que está
ocurriendo en ucrania en estos momentos
en concreto hemos empezado a estudiar el
movimiento de tropas desde las fronteras
de ucrania ahora observamos un conflicto
generalizado con bombardeos en zonas
civiles y por eso este trabajo es
realmente importante para documentar y
verificar este informe
en el centro for information resiliencia
tenemos un mapa llamado mapa del
seguimiento de rusia y ucrania
utilizamos software de código abierto
para crear un mapa generado por la
comunidad por lo que mucha gente envía
sugerencias que nos ayudan a verificar
este contenido y empezamos a desarrollar
este mapa a partir de mediados de
febrero empezamos a documentar el
conflicto en el mapa indicando donde
había disparos de proyectiles bombardeos
y disparos etcétera
[Música]
bones y pits
se desplazan
carta a un ajo el hijo
lo que hacemos es geolocalizar para
saber dónde ocurre eso significa mirar
las señales de tráfico en el fondo los
edificios los árboles y cosas por el
estilo para dar una ubicación exacta y
precisa en google maps o google cards
y con esto podemos poner un ping en el
lugar exacto donde se grabó el vídeo y
esto se ha hecho ya más de 600 veces y
eso es lo que vemos en el mapa
i
16 allí una sesión llena accesible
cada uno de estos pines representa un
vídeo que se puede ver en twitter o una
foto y nos ayuda a explicar lo que está
ocurriendo en ucrania y sus alrededores
en estos momentos con los
desplazamientos pero también con los
bombardeos que se han producido
a sus pies
[Música]
pero vamos a quitar
tenemos un conjunto de personas que
contribuyen al mapa y eso crea un efecto
de comunidad tenemos analistas de
imágenes por satélite tenemos
especialistas de desinformación que son
muy buenos analizando operaciones de
propaganda pero también tenemos
periodistas que han adquirido este tipo
de habilidades mirando los detalles más
pequeñas en google
bueno
y estas son algunas imágenes descargadas
en los últimos días de un bombardeo
narco
vemos una gran cantidad de bombardeos o
explosiones en el fondo
y hay un gran estacionamiento en la
esquina inferior derecha del vídeo hay
un estacionamiento aquí también tenemos
una especie de gran complejo aquí lo que
significa que obviamente hay
estacionamiento
por lo que hay mucha gente que entra y
sale y tenemos algunas banderas aquí
pero lo que también en el fondo no se ve
muy bien es una gran torre aquí y un
edificio rojo característico al mirar en
google nos preguntamos si podrían ser
centros comerciales we had look for
telecommunications
también buscamos torres de
telecomunicaciones
simplemente buscamos en google centros
comerciales en kharkov no hay muchos han
hardcore
así que pudimos encontrar algunos y
podríamos identificar este centro
comercial aquí en el medio en el menú se
pueden ver más talleres de reparación de
vehículos y un tipo de zona comercial
también
lo que indica que se trata de una zona
de población civil y kaiser existente
pero también que estas bombas fueron
lanzadas bastante cerca de lo que es un
centro comercial waris shopping mou un
supermercado y edificios residenciales
y esto es sólo una muestra de los 600
vídeos que hemos verificado y puesto en
el magic center de histeria es este mapa
es importante porque no sólo verifica
los vídeos sino que también rebate las
afirmaciones de los medios de
comunicación estatales rusos y del
kremlin sobre la desinformación que
están difundiendo sobre ucrania en este
momento
es todo por esta semana en los
observadores de france 24 si quieren
comunicarse con la producción del
programa los datos de contacto aparecen
en sus faltantes nosotros nos vemos la
próxima semana aquí en los observadores
hasta pronto